Hi guys, this is Diego from Bogota, Colombia.
大家好，我是来自哥伦比亚波哥大的迭戈。
Thank you for all the art that you give us, how made your mother has made so many things in my life.
感谢您给予我们的所有艺术，您的母亲如何在我的生活中创造了如此多的东西。
I was introduced to the show but would be my Victoria, the first love of my life, the one that got away.
我被介绍给这个节目，但那将是我的维多利亚，我一生的初恋，也是那个逃脱的人。
It was in season five and I was 22, but my parents went bankrupt and they couldn't pay for my studies anymore.
那是第五季，我22岁，但我的父母破产了，他们再也无力支付我的学费了。
So I watched the whole five seasons with my sisters who are four and five years younger than I am.
所以我和比我小四岁、五岁的姐妹们一起看了整整五季。
But we all agreed that during that tough time, basically going through hunger and spending our days together, watching the show, the HD press narrowed down and we really became more than siblings, we became friends, and now this new episode of re-watching it with you all three years ago, I decided to leave the boring suits and engineering life to become an artist.
但我们都同意，在那段艰难的时期，基本上是挨饿，一起度过日子，看节目，高清媒体缩小范围，我们真的不仅仅是兄弟姐妹，我们成了朋友，现在和你们一起重看三年前的新一集，我决定离开无聊的西装和工程生活，成为一名艺术家。
I've been acting for two years almost, listening to these podcast fields like another and very important academic resource, your insight, your tales, your opinions feel like a master class when being an artist.
我已经演戏快两年了，听这些播客领域就像另一个非常重要的学术资源，你的洞察力、你的故事、你的观点感觉就像作为一名艺术家的大师课。
I admire you, love your respect to so much and I love human and art.
我很钦佩你，非常喜欢你对我的尊重，我热爱人类和艺术。
And in man's way that I promise you, I will be a passionate and dedicated actor and artist every single day of my life.
我向你们保证，以男人的方式，我将在生命中的每一天成为一名充满激情和奉献的演员和艺术家。
Thank you again, you have no idea how much you have inspired my life and the artist that I am.
再次感谢你，你不知道你对我的生活和我这个艺术家的启发有多大。
I'm alone, for be soon, in New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything, in New York City.
我很快就会独自一人在纽约市，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你一切，在纽约市。
Wow Diego, thank you so much for that.
哇迭戈，非常感谢你。
an incredible letter to start this episode.
一封令人难以置信的信开始了这一集。
Maybe one of these days, one of these episodes, I won't almost burst into tears.
也许有一天，某一集，我不会差点哭出来。
Alex springs these beautiful things on us right as we, this is all in real time.
亚历克斯将这些美丽的东西像我们一样呈现在我们身上，这一切都是实时的。
We hear these for the first time as we do the episode.
当我们观看这一集时，我们第一次听到这些。
So that was really incredible.
这真是令人难以置信。
Thank you so much.
太感谢了。
We're so grateful that the show met you at the right moment.
我们非常感谢这个节目在正确的时间遇见了你。
And sometimes I really think the best compliment you can give another artist or storyteller as you made me wanna make art, you make me wanna do the thing, you know?
有时我真的认为你能给另一位艺术家或讲故事的人最好的赞美，因为你让我想做艺术，你让我想做这件事，你知道吗？
So that was really incredible.
这真是令人难以置信。
Welcome to how we made your mother.
欢迎来到我们如何塑造你的母亲。
I'm Josh Radner, I'm here with my friend Craig Thomas, hello Craig.
我是乔什·拉德纳，我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里，你好，克雷格。
Hey Josh.
嘿乔什。
Hey, we are talking about the TV show we made together from 2005 to 2014 called How I Met Your Mother.
嘿，我们正在谈论 2005 年至 2014 年我们一起制作的电视节目《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
I played Ted Mosby on that show.
我在那场演出中扮演泰德·莫斯比。
Craig co-created the show with Carter Bays And today, first season, much like when we filmed it, first season is chugging along.
克雷格与卡特·贝斯共同创作了这部剧，今天，第一季，就像我们拍摄它时一样，第一季正在顺利进行。
We are on episode 17 called Life Among the Gorillas.
我们正在观看第 17 集《大猩猩的生活》。
17 out of 22, we are barreling to the finish line.
22 人中的 17 人，我们正在冲向终点线。
We are well more than halfway.
我们已经完成一半以上了。
And yeah, it's the beginning of the end of season one arc is heating up here, which is fun to get into.
是的，这是第一季结尾的开始，这里正在升温，这很有趣。
I can't believe we're on episode 17 already.
我不敢相信我们已经播到第 17 集了。
I mean, this podcast, it's time is so strange because this is something I heard about parents that the days are slow and the years fly by.
我的意思是，这个播客，它的时间是如此奇怪，因为这是我听父母说的，日子过得很慢，岁月飞逝。
Is that what you found to be?
你发现是这样的吗？
Yeah, that is very accurate.
是的，这非常准确。
Very accurate.
非常准确。
My son is 18, just turned 18, and he was born between your two and three of him.
我儿子今年18岁了，刚满18岁，他是你们两三个孩子之间出生的。
And it's yes, it is all of a piece.
是的，这一切都是一体的。
Okay, so episode 17, Life Among the Gorillas.
好的，第 17 集《大猩猩的生活》。
This was written by, I believe, Craig Thomas and Carter Bayes.
我相信这是克雷格·托马斯和卡特·贝叶斯写的。
Is that correct?
这是正确的吗？
It was, we wrote a bunch of these in season one, that this is one of them.
我们在第一季写了很多这样的内容，这就是其中之一。
As the season started to barrel towards the finish line, we definitely jumped in and wrote a few more just to sort of steer like the, you know, this episode ends with a real cliffhanger that kind of spins you into some real drama that's about to heat up the entire ending of season one.
当这一季开始快要结束时，我们肯定会跳进去，写了一些更多的内容，只是为了引导，你知道，这一集以一个真正的悬念结束，让你陷入一些真正的戏剧，即将让第一季的整个结局升温。
But we will get there.
但我们会到达那里。
I won't start at the end.
我不会从最后开始。
Although we could.
虽然我们可以。
We'll talk about this, but I thought it was so elegant how the B story in the very last moment is the a story of the next episode, but it's teed up so smartly.
我们会讨论这个，但我认为最后一刻的 B 故事是下一集的 A 故事真是太优雅了，但它的设计非常巧妙。
So we'll get to all that.
所以我们会讲到这一切。
But Alec, when did this episode air episode 17?
但是亚历克，这一集第 17 集什么时候播出？
This aired on March 20th, 2006.
该节目于2006年3月20日播出。
A simpler time.
更简单的时光。
So Craig, talk us through the pitch.
克雷格，请告诉我们整个演讲过程。
What happens in this episode?
这一集会发生什么？
Yeah, I liked that this episode focused the a story on a Marshall dilemma.
是的，我喜欢这一集集中讲述马歇尔困境的故事。
Like you said, and then the sort of, at the end of the episode, the B story really hijacks Stills the spotlight to spin you into the next one, which is nothing that happens after 2 a.m.
就像你说的，在这一集的结尾，B 故事确实抢占了斯蒂尔的聚光灯，让你进入下一个故事，而这在凌晨 2 点之后就不会发生了。
This is Marshall wrestling with his principles versus financial realities, right?
这是马歇尔在他的原则与财务现实之间的斗争，对吗？
He's in law school, he's deeply in debt.
他在法学院读书，负债累累。
We've seen him in Lillie earlier in the season, both rack up thousands of dollars of money, dad on a suit and a wedding dress, the wedding dress sadly by destroying it.
我们在本季早些时候在《莉莉》中见过他，两人都赚了数千美元，爸爸穿着西装和婚纱，遗憾的是婚纱被毁了。
And he feels the pressure to go make some money by working sort of part-time in Barney's very gigantic and dubious company full of packed with alpha males.
他感到了压力，要通过在巴尼那家非常庞大且可疑的公司里做兼职来赚钱，这家公司充满了雄性领袖。
It all suited up like Barney.
一切都像巴尼那样合身。
And Marshall decides to go make a go of it there and see if he can make some money.
马歇尔决定去那里试一试，看看能不能赚点钱。
And he decides to try to fit in and starts to show signs that perhaps he's changing into one of those guys and Lily starts to notice.
他决定尝试融入并开始表现出迹象，表明他可能正在变成那些人中的一员，莉莉开始注意到。
And it's a problem.
这是一个问题。
Meanwhile, Ted is in that war of long distance of he's being sent much nicer care packages by Victoria, who's in Germany, and he feels like he has to somehow make that up.
与此同时，特德正处于一场远距离战争中，身在德国的维多利亚给他寄来了更好的护理包裹，他觉得自己必须以某种方式弥补这一点。
He's realizing that long distance really sucks, which of course, future Ted has now told us at least twice by this point at the beginning of this episode, being the second time.
他意识到长距离真的很糟糕，当然，未来的特德在本集开始时已经告诉我们至少两次，这是第二次。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, it strikes me as you describe the Marshall story, I feel like your 20s, there's still like your personality is somewhat still fluid.
我的意思是，当你描述马歇尔的故事时，我觉得你二十多岁了，你的性格仍然有些不稳定。
Like you're you're still like trying on costumes a little bit like, oh, maybe I'll, you know, yeah, and you're also still kind of porous and unformed enough, not all people in their 20s.
就像你一样，你仍然喜欢试穿服装，有点像，哦，也许我会，你知道，是的，而且你也仍然有点多孔和不成熟，不是所有 20 多岁的人。
But there, there isn't a thing like your friends at a certain point, it's not your family of origin or your parents that are most affecting your personalities, your peer groups, right?
但在那里，在某个时刻，没有像你的朋友那样的东西，对你的性格、你的同龄人群体影响最大的不是你的原生家庭或你的父母，对吧？
And when you fall into a certain kind of peer group.
当你落入某种同龄人群体时。
Like, I remember when I got to college, I wasn't, I was a gracious reader as a kid.
就像，我记得当我上大学时，我不是，我小时候是一个亲切的读者。
In high school, I wasn't as much.
高中的时候，我没那么厉害。
But I got into college, and I fell in with these really smart, funny group of people who were just like big readers.
但我进入了大学，和这些非常聪明、有趣的人在一起，他们就像大读者一样。
And I suddenly like, I conformed by becoming a big reader.
我突然喜欢，我通过成为一个大读者来顺从。
So I'd be like, so I get out of something.
所以我会想，所以我摆脱一些事情。
This is the best possible peer pressure.
这是最好的同伴压力。
No, it is.
不，是的。
It's the best possible peer pressure, like become a Marshall is like he's in a culture that he does not take to initially and he actually is somewhat repelled by it, but he also, for his own social survival, starts to adapt.
这是最好的同侪压力，就像成为一名马歇尔一样，他身处一种他最初并不接受的文化中，实际上他有些排斥它，但为了自己的社会生存，他也开始适应。
I mean, it's actually really smart to frame it in animal-alistic evolutionary terms.
我的意思是，用动物进化论的术语来描述它实际上非常聪明。
The anthropology of it all, and it hits right in that sweet spot of everything he thought he was going to be in a perfect world, and now he's working for this company that makes the fuzzy stuff on tennis balls, and a whole bunch of really evil shit.
这一切都是人类学，它正好击中了他认为自己将进入一个完美世界的一切的最佳点，而现在他正在为这家生产网球上的毛茸茸的东西的公司工作，还有一大堆非常邪恶的狗屎。
I really enjoyed that the speed of that montage of boom, boom, boom.
我真的很喜欢那种轰隆、轰隆、轰隆的蒙太奇的速度。
You'd see all of these horrible things that give that a go unnamed and the company wants the public to fit to focus on the tennis balls.
你会看到所有这些可怕的事情，这些事情让人们无法命名，而该公司希望公众能够关注网球。
That's that, you know, it feels very relevant at the moment.
就是这样，你知道，目前感觉非常相关。
It was from 2006, but it feels like it could be today, right, where we're very much in that world of talking about about climate change and how much or little of our efforts should be thrown at that and Marshall here he is in 2006 right in there and I enjoyed that.
那是 2006 年的事，但感觉可能是今天，对吧，我们在那个世界上谈论气候变化，以及我们应该为此付出多少努力，而马歇尔在 2006 年就在那里，我很享受这一点。
There's a very dark climate change joke in there.
这里面有一个非常黑暗的气候变化笑话。
We tried.
我们尝试过。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, they tried.
好吧，他们尝试过。
They tried.
他们尝试过。
I wish that joke felt like it was not relevant still, but here we are.
我希望这个笑话感觉仍然无关紧要，但我们已经到了。
Yeah.
是的。
I also like how the corporation is, is this Goliath National Bank or not?
我也喜欢这家公司的样子，这到底是不是歌利亚国家银行？
This is different.
这是不同的。
That's different.
那是不同的。
Well, it's called ultra cell here.
嗯，这里叫超级电池。
And I think later we, I forget how we get to Glass National Bank, if that's a subsidiary of ultra cell.
我想后来我们，我忘记了我们是如何到达 Glass National Bank 的，如果那是 ultra cell 的子公司的话。
I was really working on this in my brain.
我真的在脑子里思考这个问题。
I didn't let myself look it up because I was really trying to challenge myself to remember how we navigated that.
我没有让自己去查找它，因为我真的想挑战自己记住我们是如何度过的。
And I'm just going to be honest, I forget when and where and how we imply GNB as part of that or Barney that moves jobs.
老实说，我忘记了我们何时何地以及如何暗示 GNB 是其中的一部分，或者是 Barney 会调动工作。
Two things I want to highlight about this, this plot with Marshall is there's a kind of of how alpha am I supposed to be?
我想强调两件事，马歇尔的这个情节是我应该成为怎样的阿尔法？
How ruthless am I supposed to be?
我该有多无情？
How, like, where do my values go vis-a-vis my ambition and vice versa, you know?
我的价值观与我的野心相比如何，反之亦然，你知道吗？
And I think that, you know, that's still something I actually struggle with.
我认为，你知道，这仍然是我真正挣扎的事情。
Like how, how get out of my way world I'm gonna do, and I need to do versus, no, I'm a part of a team, I'm a part of community, I'm, my values dictate that I, you know, put my ego aside for the larger good.
就像如何，如何摆脱我要做的事情，我需要做的事情，不，我是团队的一部分，我是社区的一部分，我，我的价值观决定了我，你知道，为了更大的利益而把我的自我放在一边。
Like, there's all sorts of really big questions that are couched in this 22 minutes of comedy.
就像，这部 22 分钟的喜剧中提出了各种非常重要的问题。
And I wrote you this little day to send to you in New York City.
我今天写信给你，打算寄给在纽约的你。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
And now back to the show.
现在回到节目。
Yeah, I really like the flashback to Marshall's childhood.
是的，我真的很喜欢回忆马歇尔的童年。
Yeah.
是的。
The origin story of like when he decided to be a a superhero.
当他决定成为一名超级英雄时的起源故事。
He wanted to be an environmental superhero.
他想成为一名环保超级英雄。
He wanted to say, I'm going to save those gorillots.
他想说，我要拯救那些大猩猩。
I'm going to save their habitat.
我要拯救它们的栖息地。
And it's kind of this philosophical debate of, is it possible the older you get into adulthood?
这是一种哲学辩论，你成年后年龄越大是否有可能？
And I agree with you completely that your late 20s, you're maybe an adult.
我完全同意你的观点，二十多岁的时候，你可能已经是成年人了。
It depends on the person, but I feel like I became an adult in my 30s.
因人而异，不过我感觉30多岁就已经是成年人了。
Honestly, isn't it the prefrontal cortex?
老实说，这不是前额皮质吗？
It only settles at 25.
它只稳定在25。
You're still something like that.
你还是那个样子。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's like, here he is.
就像，他就在这里。
Marshall, he's a 27 or something and he's headed into now all his life is going to get expensive all of a sudden, right?
马歇尔，他已经 27 岁左右了，现在他的生活会突然变得昂贵，对吗？
They're in debt from the suit and the wedding dress.
他们欠了西装和婚纱的债。
They have a wedding coming up and the future and kids and all of a sudden when faced with all of that, he's, he's, now it's the first time he's really being tested about, do you mean this thing that you said you wanted to do when you were in grade school when you saw this woman gave this very sobering assessment that the gorillas would all be dead.
他们即将举行婚礼，还有未来和孩子，突然间，面对这一切，他，他，现在这是他第一次真正接受考验，你是说你在小学时说你想做的这件事吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's not the most inspiring pep talk he got, but it really landed for him and he's such an empath and a sweetheart and a compassionate guy.
这不是他得到的最鼓舞人心的鼓舞人心的话语，但它确实对他来说很重要，他是一个有同理心、甜心和富有同情心的人。
That is his mission.
这就是他的使命。
And now this is the first real test.
现在这是第一个真正的考验。
This is the first real we're going to kick the tires, we're going to come at this idea a little bit.
这是我们第一次真正尝试，我们将稍微思考一下这个想法。
The real life is going to come for you.
真正的生活将会为你而来。
Can you hold on to this thing?
这件事你能坚持住吗？
image of who you thought you'd be as a grown-up.
你认为自己长大后会成为什么样的人的形象。
And I really like that debate.
我真的很喜欢这场辩论。
I really like that it's an episode that's primarily about that.
我真的很喜欢这一集主要是关于这个的。
It's not primarily about dating and love and relationship stuff.
这主要不是关于约会、爱情和关系的事情。
Who are you?
你是谁？
Can you hold on to that best version of yourself you thought you were going to be?
你能保持你认为自己会成为的最好的自己吗？
It's also, though, it does brush up against dating and relationship and marriage, because he says, well, how am I going to provide for this family?
不过，这也确实不利于约会、人际关系和婚姻，因为他说，好吧，我该如何养活这个家庭？
How am I going to, you know, my wife is a kindergarten teacher, like what kind of salaries together, what kind of life will that buy us in New York City no less.
我该怎么办，你知道，我的妻子是一名幼儿园老师，像什么样的薪水一起，我们在纽约市会得到什么样的生活。
So it does brush up against, you know, the economic question.
所以它确实遇到了经济问题。
This is actually the other thing I wanted to bring up.
这实际上是我想提出的另一件事。
I read a really great article in The Atlantic by Sophie Gilbert this week about essentially like economics on TV.
本周，我在《大西洋月刊》上读到了索菲·吉尔伯特 (Sophie Gilbert) 撰写的一篇非常精彩的文章，内容本质上就像电视上的经济学一样。
And she asked like, when did TV becomes so filthy rich.
她问，电视什么时候变得如此肮脏丰富了。
Like when did TV, right now, TV isn't really in a moment where everyone, money's not an issue right now on TV.
就像电视什么时候出现一样，现在，电视并不是真正处于每个人、金钱现在在电视上都不是问题的时刻。
Everyone has an enormous amount of money to burn vacations to go to where people get murdered and beach houses.
每个人都有大量的钱来浪费假期去人们被谋杀的地方和海滨别墅。
And it's just like money is no object on TV right now.
就像现在钱在电视上不再是问题一样。
And she bemoans this and I think rightly that if you want TV to be a reflect, I mean, it's a tricky thing because you don't want TV to be a downer.
她对此表示哀叹，我认为如果你想让电视成为一种反映，我的意思是，这是一件棘手的事情，因为你不想让电视成为一种沮丧。
TV is still an escape, right?
电视仍然是一种逃避，对吧？
Like you still wanna go somewhere where you can get away from stuff, but you also don't wanna feel like you're in like a gilded palace that you don't relate to.
就像你仍然想去一个可以远离一切的地方，但你也不想感觉自己像一座与你无关的镀金宫殿。
And I've always admired, something I admired about this show is economics is at play.
我一直钦佩这个节目，我钦佩的一点是经济在发挥作用。
And Barney is planning these seeds of doubt about like what a man is, right?
巴尼正在计划这些怀疑的种子，就像一个男人是什么，对吗？
It's a man's job to provide everything for the woman.
为女人提供一切是男人的工作。
is very kind of old school, right?
很老派，对吧？
Lily Yesher, Lily's a kindergarten teacher, but deep down she wants the package, according to Barney, which led to some great word play Dick jokes that I really enjoy later.
莉莉·耶舍尔（Lily Yesher），莉莉是一名幼儿园老师，但根据巴尼的说法，她内心深处想要这个包裹，这导致了一些很棒的迪克笑话，我后来非常喜欢。
But there really is legitimate content into what he's saying, which is he's saying, she may say one thing, but deep down, and Barney's playing to that kind of primal sort of caveman, like very deep primordial thing that men feel, I think of, I've got to be this provider.
但他所说的确实有合理的内容，也就是说，他在说，她可能会说一件事，但在内心深处，巴尼正在扮演那种原始的穴居人，就像男人感觉到的非常深刻的原始事物，我想，我必须成为这个提供者。
And he really fucks with Marshall's head for lack of a better term and starts, plans a seat of doubt that, yes, Lily will, maybe she's not now, but she will be the woman who will want all of those things.
他真的因为缺乏更好的术语而操弄了马歇尔的脑袋，并开始计划一个怀疑的座位，是的，莉莉会，也许她现在不是，但她将是那个想要所有这些东西的女人。
Even as Lily is saying to Marshall, I don't need those things, I want you to be yourself and you're sliding into becoming someone else and I don't like it, but it's so powerful.
就像莉莉对马歇尔说的那样，我不需要那些东西，我希望你做你自己，而你正在逐渐变成另一个人，我不喜欢它，但它是如此强大。
I think that pull of what you think you're supposed to be or do as a man, and I think we are really witnessing to get to political sociological at the moment.
我认为，你认为自己作为一个男人应该成为什么样的人或应该做什么，我认为我们现在确实正在见证政治社会学的发展。
But I think we're really witnessing in our culture right now, 2025, as opposed to 2006, although it's kind of the same debate.
但我认为我们现在确实正在见证我们的文化，2025 年，而不是 2006 年，尽管这是同样的辩论。
What is a man, right?
什么是男人，对吗？
What is a man's role?
男人的角色是什么？
How does a man define himself?
男人如何定义自己？
And I think we were seeing some very wrong answers to that question, if I may be so bold.
如果我可以这么大胆的话，我认为我们看到了这个问题的一些非常错误的答案。
And we see Marshall get seduced buy some of those, maybe the sketchier version of what a man thinks he's supposed to be.
我们看到马歇尔被诱惑买了其中一些，也许是一个男人认为他应该成为的更粗略的版本。
It almost feels like you guys were a little ahead of what's going on now, like Blauman and Billson.
几乎感觉你们有点超前于现在正在发生的事情，就像布劳曼和比尔森一样。
Is that their names?
这是他们的名字吗？
Blauman and Billson?
布劳曼和比尔森？
Brian and Taryn, yeah.
布莱恩和塔林，是的。
What perfect names, by the way, Blauman and Billson.
顺便说一下，布劳曼和比尔森，多么完美的名字啊。
Those names came from pretend names we used to make up with Carl McLaren and Jamie Adamek.
这些名字来自我们过去为卡尔·麦克拉伦和杰米·阿达梅克起的假名。
We would just make up these middle manager kind of guys and those were like the names of the guys that were like characters we would sometimes just pretend to do.
我们只会编造这些中层经理之类的人，这些人的名字就像我们有时假装做的角色一样。
Yeah.
是的。
And so we stole them as a tribute to those bits to put in these sort of like these striving middle management kind of guys.
因此，我们偷走了它们，作为对这些片段的致敬，并将其放入这些努力奋斗的中层管理人员中。
And by the way, the first significant other of a him and man cast member has made an appearance.
顺便说一句，他和男演员中的第一个重要人物已经出现。
Has landed.
已落地。
Taren Kilum, Coby's friend, then Fiancé and then husband and now father of she'll her children.
塔伦·基卢姆 (Taren Kilum)，科比的朋友，然后是未婚夫，然后是丈夫，现在是她孩子们的父亲。
And there that begins a quick succession in this next batch of episodes of several other significant others.
从这里开始，其他几位重要人物的下一批剧集很快就开始了。
But this was the first one.
但这是第一个。
This opened the floodgates and then we got to come on.
这打开了闸门，然后我们就必须继续前进。
We're making up for me not having been married on the show by having Jordana on every episode of this show.
我们让乔丹娜出现在这部剧的每一集中，以此来弥补我在剧中没有结婚的遗憾。
Yes, and we finally got, that's right.
是的，我们终于明白了，没错。
And now this is your significant other.
现在这是你的另一半了。
This is my, yeah.
这是我的，是的。
So we've we've we've read it the boat.
所以我们已经读过这艘船了。
So, but also, I mean, there's a kind of like the culture in that company among those guys, like not to name any names, but it does feel like we could probably guess what podcast they're listening to today.
所以，我的意思是，这些人之间有一种类似该公司的文化，喜欢不透露任何名字，但确实感觉我们可以猜出他们今天在听什么播客。
It feels like they were in the man-a-sphere before there was such a thing, or they were like waiting for their cultural moment to come along.
感觉就像在出现这样的事情之前他们就已经处于人类领域，或者他们就像在等待他们的文化时刻的到来。
Those guys have a podcast at this point.
这些人此时有一个播客。
They have a podcast.
他们有一个播客。
They have a very mid podcast.
他们有一个非常中等的播客。
It's the blam and dulcen hour, and it is really fucking crazy.
这是抱怨和欢欣鼓舞的时刻，这真的太他妈疯狂了。
But also think of it, just the culture pleasure of Marshall Erickson from pretty liberal Minnesota Wesleyan graduate entering into this thing.
但也想一想，马歇尔·埃里克森（Marshall Erickson）来自相当自由的明尼苏达卫斯理毕业生进入这件事，这是一种文化乐趣。
He must have felt, I mean, you see, he feels really underwater and ill-equipped, but he also makes this pivot.
他一定感觉到，我的意思是，你看，他真的感觉自己在水下，装备很差，但他也做出了这个转变。
But I just think there's something so refreshing about seeing people think in your light, everyone's economic situation is affecting their choices, it's affecting whether they're going to meet their friend for dinner.
但我只是觉得看到人们从你的角度思考是一件令人耳目一新的事情，每个人的经济状况都在影响他们的选择，这会影响他们是否会和朋友一起吃晚饭。
If they have enough money, it's affecting where they can live.
如果他们有足够的钱，就会影响他们的居住地。
It's affecting what cities they're going to, what jobs they're going to take, like economics, especially in America, such a driver of so much.
它影响着他们要去哪些城市，要从事哪些工作，比如经济，尤其是在美国，这是一个如此多的驱动因素。
And I feel like it's a dereliction of duty when TV shirks looking directly at that.
我觉得当电视回避直接关注这一点时，这是一种失职。
Yeah, I agree.
是的，我同意。
I really like seeing them under legitimate financial pressure.
我真的很喜欢看到他们承受合法的财务压力。
And it's kind kind of changing who Marshall is and its decisions he's making because we've all been there in some way, where like, I mean, I remember like looking at life through that lens, like in season one of how I met your mother, like we, you know, we were all on the climb, right, Josh?
这在某种程度上改变了马歇尔的身份和他所做的决定，因为我们都以某种方式经历过那里，我的意思是，我记得通过这个镜头来看待生活，就像在第一季我如何遇见你母亲一样，就像我们一样，你知道，我们都在攀登，对吧，乔什？
We were all like, we were ambitious and hungry and we wanted this thing to work and this was our ticket, right?
我们都说，我们雄心勃勃、饥渴难耐，我们希望这件事能够成功，这就是我们的门票，对吗？
And we're chasing this thing and you're maybe like, deprioritizing other parts of your life and brain and health and whatever else is going on to like this kind of workaholic focus.
我们正在追求这个东西，你可能会喜欢，降低生活中其他部分的优先顺序，比如大脑、健康以及其他任何喜欢这种工作狂的专注。
You know, I remember thinking, I'm married, I've been married for years, we're probably gonna have a kid soon.
你知道，我记得我当时想，我已经结婚了，我已经结婚很多年了，我们可能很快就会有一个孩子。
And like all of these issues were in my brain too.
就像所有这些问题也都在我的脑海里一样。
And you know, and it's a very powerful thing to, I think for men, I mean, I don't wanna, I'm a man, so I'll only talk about it from that perspective.
你知道，这是一件非常强大的事情，我认为对于男人来说，我的意思是，我不想，我是一个男人，所以我只会从这个角度来谈论它。
But what Marshall gets seduced by there is very real.
但马歇尔所受到的诱惑是非常真实的。
And you're coming up on 30, you're in your late 20s and your 30s, all of a sudden you're looking ahead and you're thinking about children in the future.
你快到30岁了，你已经20多岁了，30多岁了，突然间你开始展望未来，想到未来的孩子。
And I really, I bought Marshall's kind of slide into the seduction.
我真的，我相信马歇尔的那种滑入诱惑的感觉。
Obviously it's funny and it's silly and me maybe tried to make it amusing, but I think it's pretty real, right?
显然这很有趣而且很愚蠢，我可能试图让它变得有趣，但我认为它很真实，对吧？
That even a guy with all of those kind of values who is a cuddly, sweet, empathetic bear of a guy, there is something seductive when someone whispers in your ear and goes like deep down your wife wants you to be rich.
即使是一个拥有所有这些价值观的男人，一个可爱、甜蜜、善解人意的男人，当有人在你耳边低语，就像你的妻子内心深处希望你富有时，也会有一些诱人的东西。
Your wife wants everything, but not only that, there's a gravitational pull to a culture.
你的妻子想要一切，但不仅如此，还有一种文化的引力。
I know a woman who moved down to Florida kind of mid-pandemic with her husband and her kids, and she was very kind of New York progressive.
我认识一位女士，她在疫情期间与丈夫和孩子搬到了佛罗里达州，她是纽约的进步派。
Her politics were just like line drive kind of New York City politics.
她的政治就像纽约市的直线驱动政治。
And she moved down to Florida, and she was surrounded by different political beliefs and she said like I still consider myself on the left end of the spectrum but it changed a lot of my thinking just being saturated in a different culture.
她搬到了佛罗里达州，她被不同的政治信仰所包围，她说我仍然认为自己处于左端，但这改变了我的很多想法，只是沉浸在不同的文化中。
So Marshall like steps into this culture and it rattles him because he also doesn't want to get made fun of at lunch.
马歇尔喜欢融入这种文化，这让他感到不安，因为他也不想在午餐时被人取笑。
He doesn't want to eat alone.
他不想一个人吃饭。
He doesn't want to feel like like he's the lame kid, right?
他不想让自己觉得自己是个瘸子，对吧？
And it's funny how at a lesson, fear of being left out never quite leaves us, right?
有趣的是，在课堂上，对被排除在外的恐惧永远不会完全消失，对吗？
Like it's always a driver.
就像它总是一个司机一样。
And that's also primal like shame of being cast out of the tribe, right?
这也是一种原始的羞耻感，就像被逐出部落一样，对吧？
I remember being in my 20s, writing for Leitcha with David Letterman, growing up all of my teen years, hating how much my father smoked cigarettes.
我记得我二十多岁的时候，和大卫·莱特曼一起为 Leitcha 写作，在我整个青少年时期，我都讨厌我父亲抽烟。
We would go on long car trips and keep me smoking with the air conditioner with like me and like a friend of mine and my mother driving I'm like just poisoning you away from the weekend.
我们会进行长途汽车旅行，让我开着空调抽烟，像我一样，像我的一个朋友和我母亲开车，我就像毒害你远离周末。
And like the whole car was smoking the cigarette.
就像整辆车都在抽烟一样。
Like every, the car itself was smoking the cigarette.
和每辆车一样，汽车本身也在冒烟。
And I was like, the one thing I know about myself, you know, life may come at me in all kinds of directions but the one thing I know is I'm never gonna smoke.
我当时想，我对自己了解的一件事是，你知道，生活可能会以各种方式向我袭来，但我知道的一件事是我永远不会吸烟。
Except when you're drunk.
除非你喝醉了。
Except when I'm drunk.
除非我喝醉了。
Yes, well, that very much to the point.
是的，嗯，这就是重点。
But I remember being at Letterman And I don't want to name names Carter Bayes was a big smoker and a couple of the other writers at Lauterman.
但我记得在莱特曼工作时，我不想透露名字。卡特·贝叶斯是个大烟鬼，还有劳特曼的其他几位作家。
And by the way, much to his credit Carter quit smoking years and years and years and years ago.
顺便说一句，值得赞扬的是卡特在很多年前就戒烟了。
In fact, we did was led to material.
事实上，我们所做的一切都是为了材料。
There was a whole hear me episode about that last thing or whatever.
关于最后一件事或其他什么，有一整集听我说。
And I somewhere in my like early mid 20s because of Carter and a couple of the other dudes were the other writers that letterman smoked.
我大约二十出头，因为卡特和其他几个家伙是莱特曼抽烟的其他作家。
I started sort of smoking, like, not even enjoying it.
我开始抽烟，甚至不喜欢抽烟。
I didn't look cool doing it.
我这样做看起来并不酷。
I'm the one person that's while smoking looks really uncool and kind of sickly.
我是唯一一个抽烟时看起来很不酷而且有点病态的人。
Like I just return a bad color.
就像我只是返回了一个坏颜色。
It does not look like James Dean at all.
它看起来一点也不像詹姆斯·迪恩。
And some of, and I was thinking like, why am I doing this?
其中一些，我在想，我为什么要这样做？
I hate this.
我讨厌这个。
I actually hate this.
我其实讨厌这个。
And our office became the smoking office because I had like windows that opened.
我们的办公室变成了吸烟办公室，因为我的窗户是可以打开的。
It was like over the Ed Sullivan theater and you know where Colbert is now.
就像在埃德·沙利文剧院上空一样，你知道科尔伯特现在在哪里。
And we were super super, people would come in there to smoke.
我们超级超级，人们会来这里抽烟。
So the fucking whole office became like an ashtray.
于是整个办公室就变成了烟灰缸。
And it was so disgusting.
这太恶心了。
And eventually I had a legal moment where I was like, I was never gonna do this.
最终我有一个合法的时刻，我想，我永远不会这样做。
And I think I'm doing this to fit in.
我想我这样做是为了适应。
I basically did like the high school thing, but in my twenties.
我基本上确实喜欢高中的事情，但在我二十多岁的时候。
I never did the high school thing in high school.
我高中的时候从来没有做过高中的事。
I never had that peer pressure in my twenties.
我二十多岁的时候从来没有受到过同辈压力。
I was like, I would smoke.
我当时想，我会抽烟。
And it wasn't a huge amount, but it was somewhat.
而且数额虽然不是很大，但也算有一点了。
And I remember just looking at myself in the mirror at some point going like, this is you were never gonna be and you're doing it to fit in with these dudes.
我记得有时候看着镜子里的自己，我会想，你永远不会成为这样的人，而你这样做是为了适应这些家伙。
Well, it's also, it's also, it's so easy to moralize.
嗯，也是，也是，道德说教太容易了。
I remember being, having a conversation with my friend Jeremy Hirschfield in eighth grade, we were at this private school, we were both about to go into this public school.
我记得八年级时与我的朋友杰里米·赫希菲尔德（Jeremy Hirschfield）交谈，我们在一所私立学校，我们都即将进入这所公立学校。
And he said, I might try alcohol.
他说，我可能会尝试喝酒。
And I said, I remember, I was so righteous, I was like, I don't need to have alcohol and have a good time, is what I said.
我说，我记得，我很正义，我当时想，我不需要喝酒，玩得开心，就是我说的。
Cut to like two months into freshman year, I'm shotgunning beers and CH Waterman's attic, you know, It's just like absolutely, I have no memory of saying that.
时间到了大一两个月，我正在用猎枪射击啤酒和 CH Waterman 的阁楼，你知道，这绝对是，我不记得说过这样的话。
But yeah, I mean, culture and that peer pressure, like it's a huge driver.
但是，是的，我的意思是，文化和同侪压力，就像它是一个巨大的驱动力。
I also think there's something really funny about the corporate critique that you guys laced into how I met your mother with Goliath National Bank and whatever this company has that got acquired perhaps by Goliath National Bank.
我还认为，你们对我如何在歌利亚国家银行认识你们母亲以及这家公司可能被歌利亚国家银行收购的任何公司的批评都非常有趣。
And that they were very generically besides the yellow fuzzy stuff on tennis balls, just involved, they had their hands in all evil, all global evil.
除了网球上的黄色毛茸茸的东西之外，他们非常笼统，只是参与其中，他们涉足了所有邪恶，所有全球邪恶。
They had their fingerprints on every aspect.
他们在各个方面都有自己的指纹。
It's weapons, it's like everything.
这是武器，就像一切一样。
And, but it's funny how you did that within like a real corporate structure, like we were not an indie like outside, this is not like a John Waters film, like this is like 20th century Fox, which at the time was owned by Rupert Murdoch, it must be said.
而且，有趣的是，你是如何在一个真正的公司结构中做到这一点的，就像我们不像外面那样是一个独立电影公司，这不像约翰·沃特斯的电影，就像这就像 20 世纪的福克斯公司，必须说，当时由鲁珀特·默多克拥有。
And you guys were doing this critique, which I thought was like pretty cool and subversive to be doing that from within.
你们正在进行这种批评，我认为从内部进行批评非常酷且具有颠覆性。
Yeah, you would throw a commercial from how I met your mother and see ads for companies like All True Cell, essentially, like, right?
是的，你会投放一则关于我如何认识你母亲的广告，并看到 All True Cell 等公司的广告，本质上，就像，对吗？
Like that was, those were our sponsors.
就像那样，那些是我们的赞助商。
So there was like, this was us hating ourselves a little bit maybe for making, for knowing we were some part of that corporate engine.
所以，我们有点讨厌自己，也许是因为我们知道自己是公司引擎的一部分。
I weren't going to work so many days and seeing that the giant Simpsons, you know, they like when you drive in the fox lathers on one of the side of one of the sound stages is a huge painting of the Simpsons, like a 50 foot tall, you know, and Star Wars and just going like, okay, remember that stuff.
我不会工作那么多天，看到巨大的辛普森一家，你知道，他们喜欢当你开车进入福克斯泡沫时，在一个摄影棚的一侧，有一幅巨大的辛普森一家画作，像一张 50 英尺高的画，你知道，还有星球大战，然后就像，好吧，记住那些东西。
Because I know the larger parent company here has some real problems happening.
因为我知道这里较大的母公司正在发生一些真正的问题。
Yeah.
是的。
I much like, I much prefer to think of ourselves as we are creative types working for this one completely separate faction like the Simpsons, which also is an unbelievable social satirical critique, right?
我非常喜欢，我更喜欢将自己视为创造性类型，为像辛普森一家这样完全独立的派别工作，这也是一种令人难以置信的社会讽刺批评，对吧？
And I would have to really meditate some days on that type of, I'm thinking about it that way, as opposed to some other way, but we had to sneak in that commentary ourselves.
我必须花几天时间认真思考这种类型，我以这种方式思考它，而不是其他方式，但我们必须自己偷偷加入这种评论。
Don't you think, though, that we are from like, we're kind of like late Gen X, you and I.
不过，你不认为我们来自于，我们有点像已故的 X 一代，你和我。
Yeah.
是的。
So we're from a generation that was like reality bites.
所以我们来自于现实的一代。
Like she chooses Ethan Hawke over Ben Stiller.
就像她选择伊桑·霍克而不是本·斯蒂勒一样。
Like it's about not selling out.
好像是为了不卖掉一样。
Swearlers.
发誓者。
Yeah, sorry about that.
是的，对此感到抱歉。
What's Nate Rogazi's thing about Sixth Sense?
内特·罗加齐 (Nate Rogazi) 对第六感有什么看法？
Like don't we're gonna rent it tonight?
我们今晚不租它吗？
Why would you ruin it?
你为什么要毁掉它？
But I know I still have that kind of like don't sell out thing I mean, that's just generational.
但我知道我仍然有那种“不要卖掉”的感觉，我的意思是，这只是一代人的事情。
But at the same time, I don't think Gen Z, they do not have that.
但与此同时，我不认为 Z 世代他们不具备这一点。
Like, they will accept ads on their TikTok if they are killing it.
比如，如果他们正在消灭 TikTok，他们就会接受 TikTok 上的广告。
Like, I just think that the idea of being a sellout is not a thing anymore.
就像，我只是认为出卖的想法已经不再是问题了。
That's why a friend of mine, Isaac Butler, a really smart writer, we went and saw, Marily, we were all along with Daniel Radcliffe when it was at New York Theater Workshop.
这就是为什么我的朋友艾萨克·巴特勒（Isaac Butler）是一位非常聪明的作家，我们去纽约剧院工作坊时看到，玛丽莉，我们和丹尼尔·雷德克利夫（Daniel Radcliffe）在一起。
And it's an amazing, if incredibly flawed musical.
这是一部令人惊叹的音乐剧，尽管存在着令人难以置信的缺陷。
And he said, I think the reason this musical doesn't work, like at its base level, is it took place in the 70s or early 80s, and it's all hinges on this notion of selling out.
他说，我认为这部音乐剧不起作用的原因是它发生在 70 年代或 80 年代初，而这一切都取决于这种售空的概念。
And that's just, it's not a thing anymore.
只是，这不再是一件事了。
Like, no one gets mad at you for taking money from a big studio or a corporation to finance your dream project.
就像，没有人会因为你从大工作室或公司拿钱来资助你的梦想项目而生气。
Like, I just think we're in a different zone, but I think you guys, we come from a kind of generation where there was a little bit of like, egh, or should we be doing this?
就像，我只是认为我们处于不同的区域，但我认为你们，我们来自这样的一代，有一点像，呃，或者我们应该这样做吗？
That's really interesting to think about.
这真的很有趣。
I wonder how this episode plays in that context in 2025.
我想知道这一集在 2025 年的背景下会如何播放。
I mean, I think it plays just because it's really, it's less about, it's in part about selling out, but it's also like selling out to this incredibly evil company that is like poisoning, clearly poisoning the environments.
我的意思是，我认为它之所以起作用只是因为它真的，它不是关于，它部分是关于出售，但它也像出售给这家极其邪恶的公司，就像中毒一样，显然毒害了环境。
The background noise is the company, but the more pressing thing is these guys and the way they talk, and the way they talk about women and the way they, just their whole ethos of how they interact and how they move through that space.
背景噪音是公司，但更紧迫的是这些家伙和他们说话的方式，以及他们谈论女性的方式和她们的方式，只是他们如何互动以及如何在这个空间中移动的整个精神。
And Marshall's like, I have to learn a new language.
马歇尔说，我必须学习一门新语言。
Like he has to code switch actually.
就像他实际上必须进行代码转换一样。
Like he's one way with Lily and Ted and Robin and then he flips into this different way of being and speaking when he's with those guys.
就像他和莉莉、泰德和罗宾在一起时是一种方式，然后当他和这些人在一起时，他就会变成一种不同的存在和说话方式。
Yeah, and I really like that Lily is a kindergarten teacher is like, no, that's just peer pressure.
是的，我真的很喜欢莉莉是一名幼儿园老师，不，这只是同辈压力。
This is not an anthropological study.
这不是一项人类学研究。
It's called peer pressure.
这就是所谓的同伴压力。
I see it with my five-year-old thing.
我用我五岁的东西看到了这一点。
We have an assembly.
我们有一个集会。
Doesn't she say we have an assembly about it?
她不是说我们要开个会讨论这件事吗？
We have an assembly every year about it.
我们每年都会召开一次会议来讨论这个问题。
It's so true.
这是真的。
It never changes.
它永远不会改变。
Here, you still feel it, right?
说到这里，你还是有感觉的，对吧？
We're like 50 years old.
我们都快50岁了
We're still moments where you're like, well, how am I been there?
我们仍然有这样的时刻，你会想，好吧，我过得怎么样？
What am I doing to fit into this situation?
我要做什么才能适应这种情况？
Am I being myself?
我是我自己吗？
Am I finally at the age where I'm just myself or crying out loud, or am I still doing that in some way?
我终于到了只能做自己或大声哭泣的年龄了吗？还是我仍然以某种方式这样做？
And I think the honest answer is we're all still doing that in some way.
我认为诚实的答案是我们仍在以某种方式这样做。
Remember how popular that book was everything?
还记得那本书有多受欢迎吗？
I need to know I learned in kindergarten.
我需要知道我在幼儿园学到了什么。
Do you guys remember the book?
大家还记得这本书吗？
Yeah, I think Lily would probably.
是的，我想莉莉可能会。
Yeah, it all applies.
是的，这一切都适用。
So a couple of things I just wanted to shout out.
有几件事我只是想大声喊出来。
I thought young Marshall was very well cast.
我认为年轻的马歇尔演员阵容非常好。
That seemed like a little adjacent seagull.
那看起来就像是附近的一只小海鸥。
Really earnest and sweet.
真是又认真又甜蜜。
Seagullian?
海鸥？
Seagullian.
海鸥。
Seagullian, yeah, I think that's right.
海鸥，是的，我认为是对的。
when Ted calls out off stage.
当特德在台下喊话时。
I love you too, Marshmallow.
我也爱你，棉花糖。
That line sounded so clearly looped, didn't it?
这句话听起来很明显是循环的，不是吗？
It did, and I was, I had the same thought, Josh, and I was like, I wonder why that got looped.
确实如此，我也有同样的想法，乔什，我想，我想知道为什么会这样循环。
Did that, I wonder if that was just like, do we add that joke?
我想知道这是否就像我们添加那个笑话一样？
I don't know if it was, but it sounded so looped.
我不知道是不是这样，但听起来很循环。
I thought it was really funny.
我觉得这真的很有趣。
Sorry, explain to some folks, explain what I agree completely.
抱歉，向一些人解释一下，解释一下我完全同意的内容。
But yes.
但是是的。
So for Tracey on, who's Sean Hayes's cousin on Smartless, We'll say that looping is when you have to go back in and add audio in post because maybe the audio got recorded wrong or you want to change the line or something like there's an off stage line you wanted to add in yeah Josh it's so funny you said that to Alec if you're not in to I turned to my wife I said like that was something happened to that line I don't remember what the next story is maybe the audio was corrupted and we just had to add that that lining up, but it did.
所以对于特雷西来说，他是《Smartless》中肖恩·海耶斯的表弟，我们会说循环是指你必须返回并在后期添加音频，因为可能音频录制错误，或者你想更改台词，或者类似你想添加台下台词之类的东西，是的，乔什，你对亚历克说，如果你不参加，我转向我的妻子，我说就像那条台词发生了什么事，我不记得下一个故事是什么，也许是音频已损坏，我们只需添加该音频即可，但确实如此。
It sounded really weird.
听起来真的很奇怪。
I feel like it was a joke that was, I think we filmed it.
我觉得这是一个笑话，我想我们把它拍了下来。
And I think something must have happened with the audio and I had to read.
我认为音频一定发生了什么事，我必须阅读。
Because it's timed, right.
因为时机正好，对吧。
It fits in, like it feels like it's shot that way.
很贴合，感觉就像是这样拍摄的。
Then I was like, why does Josh's voice sound like he's in a spaceship somewhere else other than that room?
然后我就想，为什么乔什的声音听起来像是在宇宙飞船里，而不是那个房间？
Every once in a while, I'll be watching a movie and I'll be like, that line was looped.
每隔一段时间，我就会看一部电影，然后我就会觉得，那句台词一直循环着。
Like you can, you can, but often they're pretty good about massaging it.
就像你可以的那样，你可以，但通常他们很擅长按摩。
I just wondered why that one was.
我只是想知道为什么会这样。
Where did steak sauce A1 come from?
A1牛排酱是哪里来的？
Like where did that?
比如哪里做的？
I don't remember, I was feeling like it was from maybe Matt Coon, one of our writers, and maybe in college somebody really did say that, and that was a thing, I don't have to ask Matt.
我不记得了，我感觉这可能是我们的作家之一马特·库恩（Matt Coon）说的，也许在大学里有人真的说过这句话，这是一件事，我不必问马特。
If not, I feel like it was from somebody's friend group or somebody they had studied in college, anthropologically studied some group of people.
如果不是，我觉得它来自某人的朋友团体或他们在大学里研究过的人，从人类学角度研究了某些人群。
It's a perfect kind of like, what are they saying?
这是一种完美的感觉，他们在说什么？
Do I have steak sauce on my tie?
我的领带上有牛排酱吗？
my time.
我的时间。
Poor Marshall.
可怜的马歇尔。
It's so sweet.
太甜了。
And this old man.
还有这个老人。
He musted me.
他必须我。
Fell in love with you.
爱上你了。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials.
现在是广告。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
您可能在 Bravo's Summer House 认识我，但在我的播客 More Life 中，我让您最喜欢的真人秀明星不分昼夜地参与到您通常听不到的对话中。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
深层的东西，脆弱的东西，不舒服的东西。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我与塞拉·米勒 (Sierra Miller)、德林达·梅德利 (Derinda Medley)、汤姆·施瓦茨 (Tom Schwartz)、林赛·哈伯德 (Lindsey Hubbard) 等人进行了交谈。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们在成长过程中会陷入人际关系，遇到混乱的事情，以及摄像机不转动时发生的一切。
New episodes of more life every week.
每周都有更多生活的新剧集。
Listen, wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
无论您在何处获取播客或在 YouTube 上观看，都可以收听。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束返回放映。
I loved when he said we're still engaged even if she's out of town.
我很喜欢他说即使她不在城里我们仍然订婚。
That's really funny because that sets up a future thing later where there is like I think Barney gets later way later in the series.
这真的很有趣，因为这为以后的事情奠定了基础，我认为巴尼在该系列的后期会出现。
Barney gets really angry that Marshall can't even really fantasize about other like actual women and Marshall has to go through this whole long thing.
巴尼非常生气，因为马歇尔甚至不能真正幻想其他像真正的女人一样的人，而马歇尔必须经历这整个漫长的事情。
Imagine imagining Lily's death, imagining that the funeral, imagining months past years passing and then at the end the fantasy part is he meets a woman and like says hi, hi.
想象一下莉莉的死，想象一下葬礼，想象一下过去的几个月过去了，最后幻想的部分是他遇到了一个女人，就像打招呼一样。
And that's the fantasy just that he's even open to talking another one.
这只是一种幻想，他甚至愿意谈论另一个人。
I'm getting it wrong.
我听错了。
It's like way later in the series, but it's this felt they could set that up.
这就像该系列的后期，但感觉他们可以设置它。
He can't even, he just can't even do the hypothetical really.
他甚至不能，他根本就不能真正做到这个假设。
Yeah, I mean, it's so smart how, and we'll talk about this in a moment, but setting up, you know, you know, you got Angelina Jolie at Scarlett Johansson, what would you do go?
是的，我的意思是，这太聪明了，我们稍后会讨论这个，但是设置，你知道，你知道，你在斯嘉丽·约翰逊中有安吉丽娜·朱莉，你会做什么呢？
You know, like that whole bit, which is such, it feels like a negligible throw away thing becomes this really, like, existentially fraught question at the way end.
你知道，就像那整件事一样，感觉就像一件微不足道的扔掉的东西在最后变成了一个真正充满存在主义的问题。
We have that right away.
我们马上就有了。
I remember that was sort of a big part of what this structure became.
我记得这是这个结构的一个重要组成部分。
We knew we wanted to end that.
我们知道我们想结束这一切。
That whole, what do you do go bit thing used to come from us joking around again with our assistant Karl McLaren doing, like, sort of a pretend, bro-y, fratty bit.
整个“你要做什么”这件事过去常常来自于我们和我们的助理卡尔·麦克拉伦（Karl McLaren）再次开玩笑，就像是假装的，兄弟般的，兄弟般的事情。
That was the whole, like, what do you do go?
这就是全部，就像，你要做什么？
And it was always at night.
而且总是在晚上。
It was always raining.
总是下雨。
And it was like, we would have this whole elaborate bit.
就像，我们会有这整个复杂的部分。
We essentially just transferred into the show and put on these guys that were the kind guys, we're sort of imagining that it fit in so well, and then we realized it can become dramatic at the end.
我们基本上只是转移到节目中并穿上这些善良的人，我们有点想象它非常适合，然后我们意识到它最终会变得戏剧性。
Yes, this sort of thing that this thing that you think is a complete throwaway and a completely stupid joke that just happens a couple times, little runner at the end becomes the central question of what is going to be the next episode that is going to lead to some really seismic stuff in Ted's life.
是的，这种你认为完全是一次性的事情和一个完全愚蠢的笑话只发生了几次，最后的小跑步者成为了下一集的核心问题，这将导致特德生活中发生一些真正令人震惊的事情。
And I really like that that sneaks up on you at the end.
我真的很喜欢最后偷偷出现在你身上的那一幕。
I just also realized that the word go has a double meaning at the way end because throughout The whole thing is like, what do you do go meaning answer like answer, but this one is what do you do?
我还意识到“go”这个词在最后有双重含义，因为整个事情就像，你做什么“go”意思是“答案”，但这就是“你做什么”？
Go you go you go to her.
走你走你去找她。
Yeah, you go over to her which he does which he does.
是的，你走到她身边，他就这么做了。
Yeah, yeah We'll get to that too.
是的，是的，我们也会做到这一点。
I loved when Lily said screw those guys were adorable like I Know so much about like the mythologizing like Lillian Marshall have a mythology about themselves like we're Lillian Marshall like we're the parrot where the where the is it may plus ultra is that the word like we're like the the bow ideal of a couple you know and screw these guys for for not seeing that was this the debut of of sequel doing the robot or how did he already done it he'd done some real body there's some robot in his big dance number and okay awesome and I think a couple other times he was calling that back is like this yeah I had established that by the way the other thing I like about it's 2 a.m.
我很喜欢莉莉说这些家伙很可爱，就像我知道很多，就像莉莲·马歇尔这样的神话一样，他们对自己有一个神话，就像我们是莉莲·马歇尔，就像我们是鹦鹉，在哪里，它可能加上超，这个词就像我们就像一对夫妇的弓理想，你知道，拧这些家伙，因为他们没有看到这是续集做机器人的首次亮相，或者他是怎么做到的，他已经做了一些真实的身体，里面有一些机器人他的舞曲很大，很棒，我想有几次他回电时都是这样的，是的，我已经确定了，顺便说一句，我喜欢的另一件事是凌晨 2 点。
knock knock on the front door but not the back door.
敲前门但不敲后门。
The 2 a.m.
凌晨 2 点
sort of like fit in grade it was it because I I don't remember if that was part of our initial bit but I think we we made it 2 a.m.
有点像适合年级，因为我不记得这是否是我们最初的一部分，但我想我们是在凌晨 2 点完成的。
because we knew the next episode was going to be this great study and the cut off of 2 a.m.
因为我们知道下一集将是一项伟大的研究，并在凌晨 2 点结束。
What I love Barney's please like just that's so funny yes again which set up a series long runner about not knowing what his job is and then eventually I won't blow the joke but the please of it all please mean something when we finally find out, there's an acronym for please down the line about it.
我喜欢《巴尼的请》，这太有趣了，是的，这又设置了一个关于不知道他的工作是什么的系列长跑者，然后最终我不会开这个玩笑，但当我们最终发现时，这一切的请意味着什么，有一个缩写“请”的缩写。
Oh, that's right.
哦，是这样。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
I won't say what it is because we'll just get there, you know, three years from now on the podcast.
我不会说它是什么，因为三年后我们就会在播客上到达那里。
So remember this.
所以记住这一点。
Hold on to this.
坚持住这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
How well do you think the Golden Girls joke aged?
您认为《黄金女郎》笑话的年龄如何？
Well, I mean, I guess you could argue it a bunch of ways.
嗯，我的意思是，我想你可以用很多方式来争论。
It's a bit of a troubling joke.
这是一个有点令人不安的笑话。
I think it aged well because the Golden Girls have just stayed deservedly still.
我认为它老化得很好，因为金色女孩们理应保持静止。
Yeah, yeah, yeah stayed so perennial because it's just a great show.
是啊，是啊，是啊，因为它是一场精彩的演出，所以一直如此。
And Betty White, it's like, it's all, it's all still present in pop culture.
贝蒂·怀特，就像，这一切，这一切仍然存在于流行文化中。
I was happy with it.
我很高兴。
That age better than some other pop called it aged better than the quantum leap joke two episodes earlier, for example.
例如，这个年龄比其他一些流行音乐所称的年龄更好，比前两集的量子跳跃笑话更老。
I love like smoking only when I'm drunk.
我只喜欢在喝醉的时候抽烟。
Good boy.
好孩子。
Like that's so funny.
好像这样真好笑。
Tremors of psychitude rock my body like a seizure.
精神上的颤抖像癫痫发作一样摇晃着我的身体。
That's what I wrote down.
这就是我写下的。
That's it.
就是这样。
This is another thing of like first time network debut of that sentence.
这又像是第一次网络亮相的那句话。
Yeah.
是的。
Like, another show is not doing that one.
就像，另一部剧没有做那个。
Quantum Leap, they didn't say that.
量子跃迁，他们没这么说。
Golden Girls never said that.
金童玉女从来没有说过这样的话。
Barney could turn a phrase, tremors of psychitude.
巴尼可以用一句话来形容：精神的颤抖。
And what the D-clog cat and Marshall says, wow, that was really specific.
D-clog 猫和马歇尔所说的，哇，这真的很具体。
It's really specific.
这真的很具体。
I love how Seagull played that.
我喜欢海鸥的演奏方式。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think they really did hurt each other's hands when they did some of them.
我认为他们在做某些事情时确实伤到了彼此的手。
They do a bunch of those really hard vibes.
他们做了很多非常艰难的事情。
I seem to remember them like really hard.
我似乎很难记住它们。
Yeah, we didn't have a combat choreographer for those five, like they just like hit me.
是的，我们没有为这五个人安排战斗编排，就像他们喜欢打我一样。
High five, specific high five coordinates.
高五，具体高五坐标。
You were very funny, I thought you played a very funny falling asleep on the phone.
你很搞笑，我觉得你在电话里演的睡着了很搞笑。
Oh, I like that.
哦，我喜欢这样。
With Victoria.
与维多利亚.
I like that.
我喜欢这样。
You had a very good like little physical, there was something you did.
你的身体素质非常好，你做了一些事情。
No, no, I know it is.
不，不，我知道是这样。
I did like, it's exactly something that I didn't even if melting into sleep that was good.
我确实喜欢，这正是我不喜欢的东西，即使睡着了也很好。
Jordana got distracted by our dog and I made her, I made us rewind and watch me I thought it was good enough.
乔丹娜被我们的狗分散了注意力，我让她，我让我们倒带并看着我，我认为这已经足够好了。
I wanted her to see my after.
我想让她看到我的追随者。
You need to see this.
你需要看看这个。
No, I'm not kidding.
不，我不是在开玩笑。
I really thought about it.
我真的想了一下。
That was a really funny, you slid it.
这真的很有趣，你滑倒了。
You melted into sleep by your face and your hand.
你靠着脸和手睡着了。
And it's like trying to stay on, like trying to not be asleep, like trying to let and not let the person know you're going.
这就像试图留下来，就像试图不睡觉，就像试图让或不让别人知道你要走了。
It is a great study of how shitty long distance relationships are.
这是对远距离关系有多么糟糕的一个很好的研究。
It is that idea of like you just run out of shit to say yeah, I kind of forget what the person looks like and and I actually really bought that because They don't even together a couple of months like you can be together with someone for like five years and be apart for a month or two and kind of go I'm not a hundred percent conjuring that person's face at this moment.
就是这样的想法，就像你已经没有办法说是的，我有点忘记了这个人长什么样，而且我真的买了这个，因为他们甚至不像你可以和某人在一起五年，分开一两个月，然后就这样在一起几个月，我现在还不能百分百想象出那个人的脸。
There's something off There's it's tough man.
有什么不对劲的人。
It's tough.
它太硬。
We were not wrong about the London's thing What does this mean Ted's shirt on phone with Robin?
我们对伦敦的事没有看错。泰德在和罗宾通电话时穿的衬衫是什么意思？
Oh?
哦？
Ted's?
特德的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
Were you literally falling asleep on the couch next to Jordana?
你真的是在乔丹娜旁边的沙发上睡着了吗？
You were doing the Ted's band, and I'm just writing nonsense down.
你在做特德的乐队，而我只是在写废话。
Yeah.
是的。
Ted's sure.
特德确信。
I'm fine with Robin.
我和罗宾相处得很好。
Oh, I like some of these notes.
哦，我喜欢其中一些笔记。
Like every third one, you're like, what in God's name?
就像每三个人一样，你会想，以上帝的名义怎么办？
What is that?
那是什么？
12 hours ago.
12小时前。
When I watched this.
当我看到这个的时候。
I know.
我知道。
I did think dirty deeds done dirt cheap was the perfect song for Barney to sing.
我确实认为肮脏的行为非常便宜是巴尼唱的完美歌曲。
That's like his go to perfect.
这就像他走向完美。
So I forgot.
所以我忘记了。
I had forgot.
我忘了。
forgot that was Barney's karaoke song until I was scouring new songs we should play for our How I Met Your Mother fundraiser concert that we do at Valerie Ballroom that will be another one in early 2026.
我忘记了那是巴尼的卡拉 OK 歌曲，直到我在寻找新的歌曲，我们应该为我们在瓦莱丽舞厅举办的《老爸老妈的浪漫史》筹款音乐会演奏，这将是 2026 年初的另一场音乐会。
And I was like, what song should Will Forte sing?
我想，威尔·福特应该唱哪首歌？
Neil couldn't come to that.
尼尔无法做到这一点。
It couldn't perform with us if that he was traveling.
如果他正在旅行，它就无法与我们一起表演。
And we knew we had Will Forte coming in and we're like, what song can Will Forte just scream the living bejesus out of?
我们知道威尔·福特 (Will Forte) 即将加入，我们就想，哪首歌能让威尔·福特 (Will Forte) 尖叫出神来之笔呢？
And I was like, we're looking around and it's like, it's that one.
我当时想，我们环顾四周，感觉就是那个。
Because we only play at that fundraiser concert.
因为我们只在那场筹款音乐会上演奏。
We only play songs that are either like written for how much mother or were on the soundtrack or featured.
我们只播放那些要么是为多少母亲写的歌曲，要么是原声带或精选的歌曲。
And so that was thrilling to discover that.
发现这一点真是令人兴奋。
And Will Forte came out, sang it with Carter, and killed, killed with that song.
威尔·福特出来了，和卡特一起唱了这首歌，然后用这首歌杀了，杀了。
And Neil killed it too.
尼尔也杀了它。
So let's just talk about the ending.
那么我们就来说说结局吧。
I just thought it was so brilliant, I'd forgotten one that, you know, what do you do?
我只是觉得它太棒了，我忘记了，你知道，你是做什么的？
Go comes back.
走回来了。
But I was really struck by how Ted is clearly the B story.
但令我震惊的是，特德显然是一个 B 故事。
Ted and Robin and this Victoria thing is so clearly the B story.
泰德、罗宾和维多利亚的事情显然是个B故事。
But at the very last moment, it just like tees it up as like, now we're going to follow this.
但在最后一刻，它就像开球一样，现在我们要遵循这个。
Like this is going to, this is now the eight story for the next episode.
就像这样，这就是下一集的第八个故事。
And it's such a good cliffhanger.
这是一个很好的悬念。
I think by episode 17 into 18, you've got some real emotional investment among the audience.
我认为从第 17 集到第 18 集，观众已经有了一些真正的情感投入。
I thought it was one of the better cliffhangers of episode of season one.
我认为这是第一季中最好的悬念之一。
Thanks, I love that moment.
谢谢，我喜欢那一刻。
It gives me a chill every time that ending.
每次这样的结局都让我感到一阵寒意。
It just gives, there's just when it cuts to black there and there's that little beat even before the credits come in, which we kept there to sort of let it land.
它只是给出了，就在它切到黑色的时候，甚至在片尾字幕出现之前就有了一点节拍，我们把它放在那里是为了让它落地。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I love that it sort of sneaks up on you as this dramatic ending and it really spins you into the dilemma of the next one.
我喜欢这种戏剧性的结局，它会悄悄地降临到你身上，并让你陷入下一个结局的困境。
This is what we love doing.
这就是我们喜欢做的事情。
We loved writing it as one big continuous thing.
我们喜欢把它写成一件大而连续的事情。
We didn't want it to be a box of chocolates.
我们不希望它是一盒巧克力。
We didn't want it to be standalone episode, standalone episode, you can watch anyone in any order.
我们不希望它成为独立的剧集，独立的剧集，你可以按任何顺序观看任何人。
And, you know, the network was nervous about that.
而且，你知道，网络对此感到紧张。
We got kind of a talking to you at the end of season one that we're doing too much of that kind of thing.
我们在第一季结束时曾与你们交谈过，我们做的这种事情太多了。
This was before streaming.
这是在直播之前。
This was before Netflix.
这是在 Netflix 出现之前。
Netflix was a place that sent you DVDs and red pouches at this point, 2005, six, and people didn't consume the show this way.
2005 年 6 月，Netflix 是一个向你发送 DVD 和红色小袋的地方，但人们并不以这种方式观看节目。
And we were like, but they do.
我们当时想，但他们确实这么做了。
They'll get it on the DVD and they'll watch all of it in a row or like, or by the way, why not wait, and now you have to wait a week to see what Ted's gonna do with that amazing dilemma that's just been presented to him.
他们会在 DVD 上看到它，他们会连续观看所有内容，或者顺便说一句，为什么不等一下，现在你必须等一个星期才能看到特德会如何处理刚刚呈现给他的令人惊奇的困境。
So let people sweat it out for a week and come back as opposed to like, I forget what happened last week on that How Much Mother show.
因此，让人们辛苦一周然后回来，而不是像我忘记上周在“多少母亲”节目中发生的事情一样。
I don't see the downside.
我不认为有什么缺点。
I guess it excludes people jumping in the middle, but does it really, I would argue it doesn't.
我想这排除了中间跳的人，但我认为它确实如此。
I mean, it's always essentially an argument about how much do you trust your audience?
我的意思是，这本质上始终是关于您对观众的信任程度的争论？
Yes, and we trusted our audience.
是的，我们信任我们的观众。
And God damn it, it paid off.
天哪，它得到了回报。
We're proven right by the smartest and best fans any TV show in history?
历史上最聪明、最优秀的粉丝证明我们是对的？
Well, we are at a segment of the show that we like to call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
好吧，我们现在处于节目的一个部分，我们喜欢从一位临床心理学家那里提出问题和观察，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，而且碰巧与乔什结婚了。
I love in this episode how Lily is so encouraging of Marshall following his dreams of not selling out, of not just being practical.
我喜欢在这一集里莉莉如此鼓励马歇尔追随他的梦想，不要出卖自己，而不仅仅是务实。
And it reminded me of a story about John Gottman, who's a well-known couple's therapist and researcher, who apparently when he was trying to publish his first book was rejected multiple times until one guy said, you want me to publish your book?
这让我想起了约翰·戈特曼的故事，他是一位著名的夫妇治疗师和研究员，显然，当他试图出版他的第一本书时，他被多次拒绝，直到一个人说，你想让我出版你的书吗？
Tell me now.
现在告诉我。
How do I fix my marriage with my wife?
我和妻子的婚姻该如何修复？
And John Gottman apparently said, ask her what her dreams are.
约翰·戈特曼显然说，问问她的梦想是什么。
And it worked.
它奏效了。
He published him.
他出版了他。
And the story always stuck with me because I think it highlights how fundamental it is to find a partner who really encourages you to follow your dreams.
这个故事一直萦绕在我心头，因为我认为它凸显了找到一个真正鼓励你追随梦想的伴侣是多么重要。
And I just love how the solid hymium couple here is the one that is supportive of each other's dreams.
我很喜欢这里这对坚定的 hymium 夫妇，他们支持彼此的梦想。
So my question to you guys is who was supportive of your dreams in childhood and also now.
所以我问你们的问题是，谁在童年和现在支持你们的梦想。
What a good that's a great story and a great question.
这是一个很棒的故事，也是一个很好的问题，真是太好了。
What do you do you go, Josh, your first one?
乔什，你的第一次，你会做什么？
Well, I feel like as an actor and as a person who makes things and tells stories like, there were some formative people in my life along the way.
嗯，我觉得作为一名演员和一个制作东西和讲故事的人，一路上有一些对我的生活产生影响的人。
I had and continue to have a friend named David Brown who choreographed the first musical I was in and I think he might have been the first person who told me I could do this professionally.
我有一位名叫大卫·布朗的朋友，他为我参与的第一部音乐剧编舞了，我想他可能是第一个告诉我我可以专业地做这件事的人。
And then I was at Vassar at a training program one summer, New York stage and film, and two great actors, Jane Kasmerich.
然后一年夏天，我在瓦萨学院参加了一个培训项目，纽约的舞台和电影，还有两位伟大的演员，简·卡斯默里奇。
She played the mom on Malcolm in the Middle and a bunch of other stuff, such a good actor.
她在《马尔科姆一家》和其他很多作品中扮演了妈妈，真是一位好演员。
And this other just incredible actor, Peter Fershette, I was friends with both of them.
另一位令人难以置信的演员彼得·费舍特（Peter Fershette），我和他们都是朋友。
And they both pulled me aside and said, you can do this.
他们都把我拉到一边说，你可以做到的。
You're going to be one of the people here who can do this.
你将成为这里能做到这一点的人之一。
And, you know, there was a mentor I had in school, Ken Washington, who died a couple years ago and at his memorial, I spoke.
而且，你知道，我在学校有一位导师，肯·华盛顿，他几年前去世了，我在他的追悼会上发表了讲话。
It was a bunch of Juilliard and NYU people who were really affected by him.
真正受他影响的是一群茱莉亚学院和纽约大学的人。
We had a kind of makeshift memorial at NYU.
我们在纽约大学有一个临时纪念馆。
And I got up and spoke and I said, there were times when I didn't believe that I could be an actor, but I believed that Ken believed I could be an actor.
我站起来说话，我说，有时候我不相信我可以成为一名演员，但我相信肯相信我可以成为一名演员。
And I think sometimes when you don't believe in yourself, there's like, you almost have to have like an external hard drive in the form of a person who holds the faith, like is the faith keeper for you until you can hold it yourself.
我认为有时当你不相信自己时，你几乎必须有一个像外部硬盘驱动器一样的人持有信仰，就像你的信仰守护者一样，直到你自己能够持有它。
And so I had an enormous amount of those people over the years that even now, sometimes when I'm feeling down about this or that, there's people that I call because they're so gifted at pep talks.
所以这些年来我身边有很多这样的人，即使是现在，有时当我对此或那感到沮丧时，我也会打电话给一些人，因为他们在鼓舞士气的演讲方面很有天赋。
My friend, John Morrow is like, just so he's just ready to give me the best pep talk.
我的朋友约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）就像是准备好给我最好的鼓舞人心的演讲。
And I always feel altered after talking with him.
和他交谈后我总感觉有所改变。
And you know, my wife, who also happens to be a clinical psychologist who's never seen Helen met your mother.
你知道，我的妻子恰好也是一名临床心理学家，她从未见过海伦见过你的母亲。
I've heard of her.
我听说过她。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
I think we're in her segment right now, I think we're literally in her thing.
我认为我们现在处于她的部分，我认为我们确实处于她的风格中。
I mean, in some ways like we weren't together since drama school, like we got together after I was firmly established as doing what I do, but there was no question like she understood in some sort of cellular way, what I do and why I need to do it and her ability to kind of like see what I need to do and what I need to do daily creatively, like there's never been a negotiation around that.
我的意思是，在某些方面，就像我们从戏剧学校开始就没有在一起一样，就像我们在我坚定地做自己所做的事情之后才聚在一起一样，但毫无疑问，她以某种细胞的方式理解我做什么以及为什么我需要这样做，她有能力了解我需要做什么以及我每天需要创造性地做什么，就像从来没有围绕这个进行过谈判一样。
The only negotiation would be, I think you need to do this more.
唯一的谈判是，我认为你需要做得更多。
I think you need to lean into this more.
我认为你需要更多地关注这一点。
I feel really supported in that primary relationship.
我感到在这种主要关系中得到了真正的支持。
What about you, Craig?
你呢，克雷格？
Yeah.
是的。
I like how you just lead out a timeline.
我喜欢你列出时间表的方式。
I think that's the truth of it.
我认为这就是事实。
It's like different people at different times, but the earliest ones matter so much.
就像不同时间的不同人一样，但最早的人非常重要。
I would say my My mother and father, my father, who is a writer, creative doctor and advertising.
我会说我的母亲和父亲，我的父亲是一位作家、创意医生和广告人。
And smoker.
还有吸烟者。
And big smoker, very mad man era, like an advertising smoker guy.
还有大烟鬼，非常疯狂的男人时代，就像一个广告烟鬼。
And around here and now, he's alive and probably smoking.
而此时此地，他还活着，而且很可能还在抽烟。
If he's listening to this, which I'm not sure he knows, I listen to a podcast.
如果他正在听这个，我不确定他是否知道，我会听播客。
But he would just give me cool writers to read.
但他只会给我读一些很酷的作家。
That was his way of showing his belief in me.
这是他表达对我的信任的方式。
Like, read this, read this, read this.
就像，读这个，读这个，读这个。
You should read it.
你应该阅读它。
here's John Shiver, here's Raymond Carver, here's J.D.
这是约翰·希弗 (John Shiver)，这是雷蒙德·卡弗 (Raymond Carver)，这是 J.D.
Soundger, like, and just like, he didn't give me pep talk after pep talking, but he, I knew he believed in me because he told me what to read.
Soundger，就像，就像，他没有一次又一次地给我打气，但他，我知道他相信我，因为他告诉我该读什么。
And my mother more explicitly would say, you know, saw that I was a good writer.
我母亲更明确地会说，你知道，看到我是一名优秀的作家。
She saw my schoolwork, she saw that I could write, and knew that I was thinking about doing it.
她看到了我的作业，看到了我会写作，并且知道我正在考虑这样做。
And when at a very young age, when I would have a hard day and I'd come and I'd talk about something that was terrible at school or something that was bothering me, or, you know, my parents divorcing early in high school, she would say, well, it's all grist for your mill.
当我很小的时候，当我度过了艰难的一天时，我会来谈论一些在学校里很糟糕的事情或一些困扰我的事情，或者，你知道，我的父母在高中很早就离婚了，她会说，好吧，这都是你的磨坊的谷物。
Meaning, you're gonna make something of this someday, kind of using this charmingly old timey way is the thing that my mother was born in 1802.
意思是，有一天你会用这种迷人的古老方式做出一些东西，这就是我母亲在 1802 年出生的东西。
But we ran a mill.
但我们经营一家工厂。
And no, but it was just like, you're gonna write, you'll write about this someday, which planted this seed that as you go through life and things are hard, you can turn it in art.
不，但就像，你要写，有一天你会写这个，这播下了这颗种子，当你经历生活和事情困难时，你可以把它变成艺术。
Bring it really back to our opening recording was a Diego, like, like, take those things and make it art, you know, and my mother planted that for me early.
把它真正带回我们的开场录音是迭戈，就像，就像，把这些东西变成艺术，你知道，我母亲很早就为我种下了它。
I read a novel years ago that I quite liked called Someday This Pain Will Be Useful To You.
几年前我读过一本我很喜欢的小说，名叫《有一天这种痛苦会对你有用》。
Yeah, it's a great title.
是的，这是一个很棒的标题。
And it's true, right?
这是真的，对吧？
And it's, but those moments where somebody tells you you will be able to make something of that pain.
确实如此，但那些有人告诉你你将能够摆脱这种痛苦的时刻。
I'll just say a couple other quick ones, which is Carter and I became writing partners by getting the same internship, and we're working at MTV, the series development department in the mid 1996, mid 90s, this wonderful executive there, this guy named Jeremiah Bosgang, which is an amazing name, who we're still in touch with to say, he believed in Carter and I, he's like, you guys can do this, you can be a writing team, here's what you should do, put together your packet, do this, and I will help get to an agent, which he did, got to an agent roundabout who then became our agent and was our agent all the way through our entire career till now, currently, still a agent, Matt Rice at UTI.
我只想说几个其他的快速的，那就是卡特和我通过获得相同的实习机会成为写作伙伴，我们在 MTV 工作，1996 年中期、90 年代中期的系列开发部门，那里有一位出色的主管，这个人名叫 Jeremiah Bosgang，这是一个了不起的名字，我们仍然与他保持联系，他相信卡特和我，他就像，你们可以做到这一点，你们可以成为一个写作团队，这就是你应该做的，把你的包裹放在一起，这样做，我会帮助找到一个经纪人，他做到了，找到了一个经纪人，然后他成为了我们的经纪人，并且在我们整个职业生涯中一直是我们的经纪人，直到现在，目前仍然是一名经纪人，UTI 的马特·赖斯。
And he, Matt Rice was the first guy that said, how much mother?
他，马特·赖斯，是第一个说“妈妈多少钱？”的人。
That's someone, like we told him the idea.
那是一个人，就像我们告诉他的想法一样。
And just those people that like believe in you at the right moment where you need it.
只有那些喜欢的人会在你需要的时候相信你。
And I will say my wife too, and who is a dancer choreographer, like the fact that she speaks a creative language and is talented and believed that I was talented And in my 18 years old, when I met her, she had no proof that I could really make a career of this, but seemed to have no doubt that I could.
我也会说我的妻子，她是一名舞蹈编导，她会说一种创造性的语言，很有才华，并且相信我很有才华。在我 18 岁时，当我遇见她时，她没有证据表明我真的可以以此为职业，但似乎毫不怀疑我可以。
And those people that do that for you, it's just such a gift.
那些为你做这件事的人，这就是一份礼物。
Especially because I think show business in particular, like we've talked about this, like neither of us had parents or family in the industry.
特别是因为我认为演艺界尤其如此，就像我们谈论过的那样，我们都没有父母或家人从事这个行业。
Like we were really, we made the great migration to Los Angeles.
就像我们真的一样，我们伟大地迁移到了洛杉矶。
Like we really did it in a much more kind of traditional one foot in front of the other way, but it can feel like there's such a velvet rope, like how do you get behind, like how do you get into that room, you know?
就像我们确实以一种更传统的方式做到了，一脚在前，另一脚在前，但感觉就像有一条天鹅绒绳子，就像你如何到后面，就像你如何进入那个房间，你知道吗？
How do you do that?
你是怎么做到的？
And to have someone who has a career, who is doing it kind of whisper in your ear, it's really the, I don't know, it's like a secret incantation or something, like you feel, I at least felt blessed by Jane and Peter and Peter and people that were, who knew what they were talking about and who felt like they recognized something in me and said, no, no, no, you're one of us.
有一个有事业的人在你耳边低语，这真的是，我不知道，这就像一个秘密咒语或什么的，就像你感觉到的那样，我至少感到简和彼得和彼得以及那些人的祝福，他们知道他们在谈论什么，他们觉得他们认出了我身上的某些东西，并说，不，不，不，你是我们中的一员。
You know, it was, I mean, it, you know, yeah, it feels like it gives you a little golden ticket, right?
你知道，我的意思是，它，你知道，是的，感觉就像给了你一张金票，对吧？
It does.
确实如此。
And yeah, what if Lily had said to Marshall, yeah, go work for that place for five years.
是的，如果莉莉对马歇尔说，是的，去那个地方工作五年怎么办？
We need the money versus no, stay the guy I fell in love with and we're going to figure it out.
我们需要钱而不是不，保持我所爱的人，我们会解决这个问题。
That's a big difference.
这是一个很大的区别。
That's what a great spouse does is they remind you who you are because we have amnesia about who we are so often and they're like they hold they keep the pilot light lit of no this is that's not who you are you know well great question very supportive question the question in and of itself was proof positive of what you what you just said about your lovely life so thank you dronetta welcome back we are at the third act of our episode where we like to to read some listener mail.
这就是一个伟大的配偶所做的，他们会提醒你你是谁，因为我们经常忘记自己是谁，他们就像他们保持着指示灯亮着不，这不是你是谁，你很清楚，很好的问题，非常有支持性的问题，这个问题本身就证明了你刚才所说的关于你可爱的生活，所以谢谢你，德罗内塔，欢迎回来，我们现在处于剧集的第三幕，我们想阅读一些听众的邮件。
If you would like to write us or to record a voice note that might end up at the beginning of the show or a letter, write a letter that will perhaps be at the end of the show, go to howwemadeyourmother.com or you can even go quimium.com, is that right?
如果您想写信给我们或录制可能出现在节目开头的语音注释或一封信，请写一封可能出现在节目结尾的信，请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com，或者您甚至可以访问 quimium.com，对吗？
Alex?
亚历克斯？
You can.
你可以。
Yeah.
是的。
H-W-I-M.
H-W-I-M。
Wait.
等待。
M.L.M., H.W.M.L.M., how will you make your mother?
M.L.M.，H.W.M.L.M.，你会怎样做你的母亲？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是啊，是啊，是啊。
Think about it.
想一想。
And go up to contact, and it should be clear from there how to submit to us.
并上去联系，从那里应该清楚如何提交给我们。
And Alec, what are you?
还有亚历克，你是谁？
Are you jumping in?
你跳进去吗？
What's it?
是什么？
What do I see on your face?
我在你脸上看到了什么？
In the middle of this episode, I suddenly remembered, yes, the letter I've given you is lovely, but I have a better letter, and I want you to get it right now.
在这一集的中间，我突然想起，是的，我给你的信很可爱，但我有一封更好的信，我希望你现在就收到它。
So I'm literally emailing you this new letter right now.
所以我现在就通过电子邮件给您发送这封新信。
This is live on air.
这是现场直播。
Here we go.
开始了。
And as you get it, Josh, just go ahead with it.
当你明白了，乔什，就继续吧。
Oh my God, I don't even have it yet.
天哪，我还没拥有呢。
So, oh no, there it is.
所以，哦不，就在那里。
I got it.
我得到了它。
There it is.
就在那里。
Okay, I love the audience can experience our slow internet.
好的，我喜欢观众可以体验我们缓慢的互联网。
Here we go.
开始了。
All right.
好的。
Okay.
Very exciting.
非常令人兴奋。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Oh, should I read this, Alec?
哦，我应该读这个吗，亚历克？
All right, why don't you come here, guys?
好吧，伙计们，你们为什么不来这里？
Right.
正确的。
Okay, so this is hot off the press.
好吧，这已经是媒体热议的话题了。
This just came in or you just remembered this one?
这是刚刚出现的还是您刚刚记住了这个？
I just remembered.
我刚刚想起来了。
Okay, so this is from Steve Olson.
好的，这是史蒂夫·奥尔森发来的。
our Emmy winning multiple Emmy winning set designer, production designer for How I Met Your Mother.
我们的艾美奖获奖者多次艾美奖获奖布景设计师，《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的制作设计师。
We did talk about him a few episodes ago and we talked about how great he is and that he really knew the bar when he wanted to make McLarens like, which is McGee's because he lived right around the corner.
几集前我们确实谈论过他，我们谈论过他是多么伟大，当他想让迈凯伦像麦基那样时，他真的很了解酒吧，因为他就住在拐角处。
I think this letter is gonna speak to that.
我想这封信会谈到这一点。
Hot off the process, so here we go.
整个过程很热，所以我们开始吧。
I'm learning this in real time.
我正在实时学习这一点。
Josh Craig and Alec says, Steve, wow.
乔什·克雷格和亚历克说，史蒂夫，哇。
Thanks so much for the shout out on the latest episode of how we made your mother general questions podcast.
非常感谢您对我们如何制作您母亲一般问题播客的最新一集的大声疾呼。
It was really a thrill.
这真是令人兴奋。
My kids got a kick out of it too.
我的孩子们也从中得到了乐趣。
They have both watched the entire series multiple times and can name any episode way faster than I can.
他们都多次观看了整个系列，并且可以比我更快地说出任何情节。
It has been so wonderful listening and watching your podcast.
听和观看你的播客真是太棒了。
It takes me back to that amazing time work on how much your mother.
这让我回想起那段令人惊叹的时光，你的母亲付出了多少努力。
It really was an honor to have had the responsibility to create the visual world for this legendary show.
能够有责任为这部传奇剧创造视觉世界，我真的很荣幸。
Steve was so good at doing that, by the way.
顺便说一句，史蒂夫非常擅长这样做。
That's in the letter, Steve added that in the letter.
史蒂夫在信中补充了这一点。
Yeah, he wrote, that was, I'm just reading it for video.
是的，他写道，那就是，我只是为了视频而读它。
He's really cocky from those Emmy, all those Emmys.
他因为那些艾美奖而感到非常自大，所有这些艾美奖。
And Craig, you had it, he talks about himself in the third person.
克雷格，你说得对，他用第三人称谈论自己。
And Craig, you had it right.
克雷格，你说得对。
I did live in NYC for quite a while, 13 years to be precise for my early 20s to my late 30s.
我确实在纽约住了很长一段时间，准确地说是 13 年，从 20 岁出头到 30 岁末。
And I feel like I lived through so many of the experiences that Ted and Marshall encountered.
我觉得我经历过泰德和马歇尔遇到的很多经历。
I related to them so much.
我和他们有很多关系。
I related to Ted because I was a single guy, a designer living in the big city, trying to find my way professionally and romantically looking for the one.
我和泰德有联系是因为我是一个单身汉，一个住在大城市的设计师，试图在职业和浪漫上寻找自己的出路。
I also related to Marshall because like Marshall, I am from Minnesota.
我也和马歇尔有联系，因为像马歇尔一样，我来自明尼苏达州。
Wow, I forgot that Steve, forgive me.
哇，我忘了史蒂夫，请原谅我。
That's not in the letter.
信里没有这么说。
And I have always been accused by New Yorkers of being too earnest, too honest, and lacking the native New York snark and sarcasm.
纽约人一直指责我太认真、太诚实，缺乏纽约人特有的尖酸刻薄和讽刺。
Now I mentioned mother meant so much to me.
现在我提到母亲对我来说意义重大。
It was the longest show I've worked on by many, many years.
这是我多年来参与过的最长的演出。
And as you guys have reiterated so often, it immediately became a family.
正如你们经常重申的那样，它立即成为一个家庭。
Coming to work each day was always a joy.
每天上班总是一件快乐的事。
And I always looked forward to seeing the next script or outline and to start working on the next wonderful bizarre, cool, amazing set.
我总是期待着看到下一个剧本或大纲，并开始制作下一个奇妙、酷炫、令人惊叹的场景。
Thank you for those nine years of creative playground.
感谢您九年来的创意游乐场。
Thank you for this walk down memory land.
感谢您走过记忆的土地。
Sincerely, Steve, Steve, we love you.
真诚的，史蒂夫，史蒂夫，我们爱你。
He was, you could not scare Steve Olson if you tried.
他是，即使你尝试，你也吓不到史蒂夫·奥尔森。
We would throw insane stuff at him on a really short clock sometimes.
有时我们会在很短的时间内向他扔一些疯狂的东西。
And he would do it and he would create it all.
他会做到这一点，他会创造这一切。
And then it would get torn down on Wednesday night and a whole new thing would come up Thursday morning.
然后它会在周三晚上被拆除，周四早上就会出现一个全新的东西。
I mean, overnight and a Thursday morning.
我的意思是，过夜和周四早上。
He was just so good, he really deserved those Emmys.
他太棒了，他真的值得那些艾美奖。
And a lesser production designer would have been, would have had some sort of a stress-based breakdown based on how much we asked of them.
一个较小的制作设计师可能会根据我们对他们的要求程度进行某种基于压力的崩溃。
And Steve was just as cool as a cucumber.
史蒂夫就像黄瓜一样冷静。
Well, he also, I think that Susie Greenberg, Steve Olson, Pam, these were just unflappable people.
嗯，我认为他还有苏西·格林伯格、史蒂夫·奥尔森、帕姆，这些人都是镇定自若的人。
Unflappable.
镇定自若。
Could not rattle these people.
不能惊动这些人。
They were, you want them in a foxhole, you know?
他们是，你希望他们在散兵坑里，你知道吗？
They were just- They were challenged, accepted, that's what they were.
他们只是——他们受到挑战，被接受，这就是他们。
But also shout out, not just to Steve, but to his team.
但也要大声喊出来，不仅是对史蒂夫，而且是对他的团队。
I mean, you'd shoot all day Wednesday late.
我的意思是，周三晚些时候你会拍摄一整天。
You'd come in Thursday morning and the set you shot in was gone.
你周四早上来的时候，你拍摄的布景已经不见了。
A whole new set was thrown up.
一套全新的组合被抛出。
And sometimes you'd be leaving and they'd already be breaking down the set.
有时你要离开，他们已经把布景拆散了。
You just shot in like 12 minutes earlier.
你大约 12 分钟前刚刚射门。
Like I hope we got that scene because that thing is getting torn the half apart.
就像我希望我们能看到那个场景，因为那东西被撕成了两半。
It's unbelievable, yeah.
真是令人难以置信，是的。
Yeah, yeah, your whole team, Steve, was amazing.
是的，是的，你的整个团队，史蒂夫，都很棒。
All the accolades were well deserved.
所有的荣誉都是当之无愧的。
And shout out to Steve's kids who loved the show.
并向喜欢这个节目的史蒂夫的孩子们大声喊叫。
Yeah, thanks.
是的，谢谢。
We're happier.
我们更快乐了。
Appreciate your dad's work.
欣赏你爸爸的工作。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任监制。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Madica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Madica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，我们的数字内容制作人（又名 Gen Z Master）是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些商品吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
单击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 的《Muse Letters》，在 CraigThomasRider.com 斜杠小说上订购克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 的处女作，你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死亡父亲协会》(Dead Fathers Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解您如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持下才得以实现的。
people will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。